hello and thank you for joining us for
today's presentation
part of our agilent cell analysis global
conference
i'm susie valdez of elaborate and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you'd like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have done for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen i now present
today's speaker
brad larson a field application
scientist at biotech
instruments for a complete biography on
brad please visit the biography tab at
the top of your screen
fred you may now begin your presentation
welcome sir
thank you for that introduction hello
i'm brad larsen from biotech instruments
i'd like to thank the organizers of this
event and agilent for
asking me to speak to you today as part
of the immuno oncology
and cancer biology virtual conference
the field of cancer research
has seen a number of advances aimed at
increasing the efficacy
of treatment reducing toxic side effects
and decreasing attrition rates of drug
candidates
these include the increased use of
immunotherapies as well as the use of 3d
cell culture techniques
and primary or stem cell-derived
organoids
that work together to create infiscal
models
that better mimic the in vivo
environment
today i'm going to focus specifically on
how
3d t cell mediated cytotoxicity
tumor invasion and small intestinal
organoid
assay procedures can be monitored using
digital bright field or
fluorescent wide field microscopy and
quantified
using cellular analysis techniques
before looking further at the
applications though
i'd like to give just a short background
on biotech for those not familiar with
our company
biotech was founded in 1968 by
dr norman alpert a professor and
researcher at the university of vermont
and since our early days the company has
had a focus
on instrumentation for microplates that
continued
over 50 years
then in 2019 biotech
became a part of agilent and is now
positioned within agilent's
selenal function
throughout biotech's history we have
focused on
four main instrumentation segments
liquid handling
including washing pmt
based microplate reader detection
robotics to accommodate multi-plate
applications
and finally imaging and microscopy
with a variety of inspiration that i
just mentioned
we are able to help scientists and
clinicians
performing research not only in
immuno-oncology
and other types of cancer but also
research within a wide variety of
disease fields
as well as environmental research
agricultural research and more
so now if we begin to look at the
individual applications
the first that i'm going to cover
demonstrates a way to analyze t-cell
activation
as part of as part of adaptive t-cell
therapy
and then use the activated t cells in a
downstream
t-cell mediated cytotoxicity assay
the entire process consists of three
portions that are carried out
over an 18-day period
the first is the directed activation of
the t
cells in the second the target
cancer cells are plated in a 2d or 3d
manner
and then in the third the stained
activated t
cells are added to the target cells and
the t cell induced cytotoxicity of
target cells
is monitored over the next seven days
so in the next slides we'll focus on
performing
imaging and analysis of t cell
activation
the two instruments that were used to
complete
project times cell imaging multi-mode
reader
and the biospot 8 automated incubator
the citation 5 combines the ability to
perform pmt-based
microplate reading and automated
physical
uh microscop microscopy in one
instrument
on the microscopy side the instrument
can capture images
using bright fields colored right field
phase contrast
and fluorescence modes the citation five
can hold
up to six objectives ranging from 1.25
to 60x
and can also be equipped with up to four
fluorescence imaging cubes
with currently over 20 channels to
choose from
the biospot 8 is a benchtop incubator
that can hold not only micro microplates
but a wide variety of vessels
it's equipped with environmental
controls for
temperature and co2o2 as well
as a water pan and the ability to
monitor humidity
the robotic arm as you see in the front
of the instrument
automatically moves the plates from the
biospa to the connected
liquid handler reader or imager at the
appropriate time
as described in the biospa scheduling
software
for this particular project following
setup of the t-cell activation
assay the plates were placed into the
biospa for incubation
and time the plates were moved to the
citation 5 where bright field imaging
was carried out
the setup of the t-cell activation was
performed in the following manner
we carried out directed activation where
t-cells are cultured in the presence of
the
mda mb231 target cells which secretes
several soluble factors including
cytokines
to increase t cell proliferation and
sensitize the t
cells to enhance their ability to seek
out the specific
target cancer cells when used in
cell-mediated
cytotoxic cytotoxicity applications
however we also realized that we needed
to separate
the t cells and target cells at the end
of the experiment to only move the t
cells onto the next portion of the
process
so to do this we incorporated
nanoshuttle
paramagnetic particles from grinder bio1
the particles were first attached to the
target cells
and aggregated together by placing the
24 well plates on top of a 384
well magnet creating the target cell
configuration
that you can see in the picture in the
slide to test the effect
of directed activation to different
wells we added varying concentrations
of turboblast ranging from 100
target cells and no fibroblasts to zero
percent target
cells and one hundred percent
fibroblasts
t cells were then added to the wells in
addition to
anti cd3 anti cd28
and a range of il2 super kind to start
activation
an overview of the entire activation
process
then looks like this again we see
the tar being added on day one and
aggregated on top of the 384 world
magnet for four days
on day five media is removed and the t
cells are added
along with anti cd3 and anti cd28
antibodies
and il2 super kind to begin the
activation process
the plate is added to the biospa for
three days
and transferred to the citation five
every six hours
to capture brightfield images of each
well to monitor
activation before being transferred back
to the biospot
on day 8 the plate is again placed on
top of the 384 well magnet
spent media is removed and fresh media
with antibodies and super kind is added
activation continues for another three
days before the
before the plate is placed back onto the
384 well magnet a final time
and t-cells are removed for staining
the il-2 super kind that we used was
from adipogen
it is a variant of il-2 that contains
mutations to allow the super kind to
bind to il2
receptors with a high affinity
and the reason for using this super kind
is that the end result
of the mutations is that compared to
native il-2
the superkind provides superior
expansion of cytotoxic and effector t
cells which which elicit a diminished
uh toxic effect on those cells during
the activation process
so then for imaging in order to capture
images of the entire well
a 12 row by 10 column montage was set up
in the gen 5 imaging procedure what
you're seeing
here in this slide is a portion of that
montage
then following the completion of each
imaging iteration
performed every six hours the images
were
stitched to image processing step also
in gen 5.
as images were captured kinetically you
can also create movie files
to visualize the effect of the treatment
in each well
the kinetic images i'm going to show you
the left were from a well seated with
500 000
t cells followed by antibodies
and 100 uh nanograms per ml aisle 2
super kind
while the images on the right were from
an
um a negative control well again seated
with 500 000 thousand t cells and
antibodies
but no i'll to super kind so i'll start
those uh movie files now
and as you can see from the kinetic
image movie file
there's a dramatic increase in t cell
proliferation
and cell clumping in
well complex isle 2 super kind which is
as expected
as increased proliferation and clumping
are
a common phenotypic indicator of t cell
activation
to quantify the level of activation
confluence measurements
were conducted on captured images
using an image analysis step in the gen
software
a threshold signal in the bright fields
channel is established
the way this is done is that a line can
be drawn
across a portion of the image to see the
actual
signal in areas of background and areas
containing cells
which you can see was done here on this
slide
in the graph on the left you can see
that areas
of the image containing fewer cells have
a higher signal
and then when our drawn line goes
through an
area of highly clumped cells the signal
drops dramatically
the threshold value that is chosen
includes areas of the image containing
cells
and have a low bright field signal which
in the image shown are in black or the
blue color
while background areas of the image
containing no
cells and having a higher signal again
in the image
i'm showing here are in yellow are
exploited
the final result is a normalized uh
and the image here containing a large
number of cells
was determined to be 73.8 percent
confluent
when confluence values are plotted over
time from wells containing either
one hundred thousand or five hundred
thousand t
cells for all the different
concentrations of the il2 superkind
tested
you can see how increased levels of the
super kind
cause an increase in confluence
and then by calculating the area under
the curve
for the two cell for the two t cell
concentrations
either based upon super kind
concentration or
time we can infer that increases in both
positively affect the level of t cell
activation
so then in the next portion of the
project
this involved the performance of the
t-cell mediated
cytotoxicity assay the same
instrumentation set up
including the citation 5 and the biospa
was used
here after the test plates were prepared
they were placed into the biospa and
again automatically transferred
to the citation this time to perform
both bright fields and fluorescence
imaging
using those images cellular analysis
methods were run
to determine t cell induced target cell
cytotoxicity over time
if we look back to see how this fits
into the
original project workflow we see that on
day 9 the target cell model which
included
co-cultured fibroblasts was added to the
spheroid plates
and aggregated together for 48 hours to
create the 3d model
the same was repeated on day 10 in 2d
then on day 11 t cells were
added to the ratios of 20 to 1 10 to 1
or 5 to 1 compared to the number of
co-cultured target cells
the plates were placed into the biospa
as previously explained
and automatically transferred to the
citation every four
hours this time to perform the
brightfield and fluorescent imaging
this continued over a seven day period
the layout here shows the different
combinations that were tested
in the cell-mediated cytotoxicity app
t-cells that were activated using
different levels
of directed activation as indicated
by the different colors were combined
with target cells at varying ratios
as indicated by the different letters
this made for multiple combinations to
be tested
including a no t cell and negative
control for each set of conditions
images were captured every four hours
using
three different imaging channels
to capture all cells in the cold culture
the propidium iodide channel to image
necrotic cells
and the sci-fi channel to distinguish
cell tracker deep red stained
t-cells from the other cell types
the first step when looking at the
overlaid images of the 2d
and 3d cultured cells was to confirm
that t
cells bound to the target cell models
and then induced target cell toxicity
as you can see from the overlaid bright
field cy5
2d cell image at the top left of the
slide
the t cells are clustering around the
target cells
within the image for the image of
the 3d culture target cells at the top
right
of the slide you can also see a number
of t-cells binding
to the 3-d what is also
interesting here is that you can see
that the rest of
the t-slate are moving towards the
tumeric
when we look at the overlaid bright
field perpedium iodide
images at the bottom of the slide we can
also see necrotic cells
at the same positions of t cell binding
as witnessed by an increase in propidium
iodide
signal at those same locations
when looking at images captured over
time this time we're just looking
at overlaid uh perpidium iodide and cy5
channels
to better see the label t cells and
induce
cytotoxicity you can also see that the
number of necrotic cells dramatically
increase over time
confirming that binding of the t cells
to the target cells does
induce a toxic effect on the target cell
the same can be said for the target
cells cultured
in 3d this time i've included the bright
field channel
with the pi and sci-fi channels so you
can see
what happens to the tumoroid over time
again we see
t cell clustering and binding causing an
increase
in necrotic cells within the tumeric
then by seven days of incubation the
tumoroid
literally is destroyed by the t-cell
interaction
causing a dispersal of cells within the
image
we can then use the captured images to
visually ascertain the potential effect
of the different conditions that were
tested
when we first look at t cell
at t cell concentration in the three
video clips
of kinetically captured images i'm going
to show you
you'll notice that t cell binding and
the number of
necrotic cells increases faster with an
increased concentration
of t cells i'm going to start those
video clips for you now
what you'll also notice from the 3d
models as i mentioned in the previous
slide
that the tumorous literally explode
after
exposure to the t cells i'm just going
to show you each of those one more time
to kind of let you really see what
happens
and this effect has been reported in
other studies so is certainly not
unexpected
the effect of the directed activation
using the
mda mb231 breast cancer cells can also
be visualized
by looking at images captured at the
same time from wells
containing completely unactivated t
cells
or t cells activated with antibodies in
il-2
in the presence of either 0 50
75 or 100 target breast cell
cancer target breast cancer cells
it is easy to see that directed
activation enables the t
cells to have a much greater cytotoxic
effect
on the cancer cell model
cellular analysis was also performed on
each captured image in order to quantify
the level of induced cytotoxicity
from the t cell treatment a separate
analysis
was performed for the target cells
cultured either
in 2d or 3d using optimized crates
for 2d cultured cells minimum and
maximum object size
limits were set for individual necrotic
cells
such as what you see in the image on the
left
of the slide with target cells uh
cultured in 3d
the cells obviously exist as much larger
uh clusters so um even when the
hemorrhoid begins to break apart
therefore minimum and maximum size
limits
need to be increased to accommodate the
change
in cell configuration
then finally to limit the contribution
of any
dead t cells to the number uh to the
numbers
coming out of the analysis whether using
2d or
3d cultured cells we use the fact that t
cells have a much smaller size in
relation to the target cancer cells
and set a minimum object size that was
larger
than a t cell therefore they would not
be masked
and would not skew the results of our
analysis
so after performing the cellular
analysis
we normalize the data to account for
slight variations in
cell plating we did this in the
following manner
for 2d cultured target cells we divided
the necrotic cell number at each time
point
for treated wells by the necrotic cell
number
for no t cell for the note
cell troll well a similar method
was performed for a 3d culture target
cell however here
because cell counts were inaccurate due
to the aggregated manner of the cancer
cells we used another
metric generated by gen 5 that being the
total perpedium iodide
signal coming from the captured image
when performing the normalization
process an interesting phenomenon was
observed
if you look at the graph on the left of
the slide
for targets that's cultured in 2d you'll
see
that the necrotic cell ratio
for wells containing target cells
and t cells that went through different
levels of directed activation
target cell ratio rises quickly and in
proportion to the level of activation
as we would expect but then drops just
as quickly
after approximately 24 hours of
incubation
this is until we look at the black line
in the graph which is the number of
necrotic
cells in the no t cell negative control
well
what is happening is that the 2d culture
target cells begin to lose viability
after about 24 hours because of being
cultured
in 2d so as the number of necrotic cells
in the negative control goes up the
necrotic cell ratio
goes down if we look at the graph
on the right side of the slide however
for target
cancer cells cultured in 3d we see
that the cancer cells in the no t cell
negative control
wells maintain a much higher level of
viability throughout the entire process
therefore the ratio of pi signal from
treated wells compared to the pi signal
from negative control wells
increases over time as we would expect
these results are a really great example
this type of long-term
t-cell mediated cytotoxicity experiment
uh makes the most sense using a 3d
culture
cancer cell model in in the 2d
culture model it is difficult to have
confidence
after within 24 hours however with a 3d
cancer cell model one can be confident
in the data generated
all throughout the seven day incubation
period
type of data normalization and
comparison was also performed
for wells containing 100 directly
activated t
cells at ratios of 20 10
and 5 to 1 over target cancer cell
numbers
the effect of higher t-cell ratios is
quite obvious causing a higher necrotic
cell ratio
for 2d cultured cells and a faster
induction
of target cell necrosis in in 3d
cultured cells
that the difference in the viability of
the cancer cells over time again
affects the ratios for 2d cultured
cancer cells
as it did in the previous comparison
then finally as i mentioned before when
using a 3d
cell culture format for the target cell
model
incubation when act uh incubate
incubation with activated t cells
literally causes
the the tumor to disintegrate over time
this explosion causes a release of cells
and
extracellular matrix within the well
that can be visualized
using bright field imaging the image at
the top
left shows a tumoroid at time 0 that is
still intact
then with increased incubation you can
see
in the image at the top right that the
tumoroid breaks apart
and the releases release of cells and
extracellular matrix
begins this continues as you look at the
image
on the bottom left and finally the image
at the bottom right
what is important to note is that no
changes were made
in exposure of any of these images
or the any changes in the brightness and
contrast settings the increased darkness
is due to the scattering of the cells
and ecm
across the image and across the entire
well
so using the the immobility in gen 5
that i explained earlier to determine
the confluence of the activated t cells
we can
we can perform the same type of
measurement here
by setting a threshold signal once again
to include pixels in the image with a
lower right field signal
and excluding pixels with a higher right
field signal
we can use confluence to also track
induced target cell necrosis if we focus
on the different teeth cell
to joe's we see that again the
confluence values increase the fastest
for wells with a 21 ratio
followed by 10 to 1 and 5 to 1. this
demonstrates
another way that induced cytotoxicity
can be measured
using a 3d target cell cancer model and
label-free imaging
moving away from amino oncology now in
the second project that i'm going to
talk about uh
we were again looking to demonstrate a
method using the citation imager and
biospa
to accurately image and analyze another
3d model
in a kinetic fashion over a seven day
period
this time as part of a means to assess
the metastatic ability of
our target cancer cell models and ways
to inhibit invasion
one tuberoid model consisted of
co-cultured gfp expressing u87
glitoblastoma cells known to be highly
metastatic
and rfp expressing primary fibroblasts
while the other consisted of a far less
invasive glioblastoma multiforme cell
line
ln 220 knot stained with cell tracker
deep red
and again rfp expressing fibroblasts
to image all the different cell types we
used brightfield
to capture the complete invading
structure the
gfp channel to image the u87 cells
the rfp channel to image the fibroblast
and the sci-5 channel to image
the ln-229 cell again because of the
capacity of the citation 5
all the fluorescence imaging cubes for
these channels
could be installed on the instrument at
the same time
so imaging of all channels could be
accomplished
in the same run also because of the size
of the invading structures we added a
three row by two column montage
to ensure that no portions of the
invading tumeroids were missed
in in the captured images these were
then stitched back together
following image capture in addition
because in being placed in the x y and z
planes
we incorporated a 20 v stack
a z-projection algorithm was applied to
the captured
images to take the most in-focus
portions of
each image and return a final in focus
image
that could be used for analysis and once
again
as uh previously mentioned image capture
took place
in a kinetic fashion every 12 hours over
a seven day period
an advantage of being able to image not
only the complete invading 3d structure
but also the individual cell types in
our coal culture
is that you can determine the invasive
ability of each cell type
in the u87 fibroblast co culture
when looking at the gfp image you can
see that the u87 glioblastoma cells are
highly invasive as expected
whereas by looking at the rfp image
you see that the fibroblasts are much
less invasive
and tend to stay within the original
turtle area
the extent of invasion can also be
quantified
using methods similar to what i'm going
to demonstrate in a few slots
as i mentioned uh previously to
accurately image tumoroid invasion
we incorporated a number of uh
capabilities available within the gen 5
software
u87 glioblastoma multi are highly
invasive
therefore over the seven day incubation
period
the podia extend out away from the
original
embedded spheroid to a great deal as you
can see
in the images on the slide the
three row by two column montage of which
i'm showing for the images captured here
centered in the middle of the well
ensured that
all areas of the invading structure were
captured
within the sixth total aim and if the
steroids were slightly off center
after the addition of the major gel
overlay
then if you look at the images on this
slide
you can see that the six image tiles
from the montage
are able to be stitched together to
create accurate complete images
of the invading tumerite the four
pictures
on the left of the slide also
demonstrate how
images of invasion were captured in
stack 20 total slices were taken
but i'm only showing uh four here for
simplicity's sake
you can see at the different z heights
that various portions of the structure
are in focus
then when we apply the z projection
algorithm to create the final stitched
z projected images on the right side of
the slide
you can see how all portions of the
tumeric
including the innovative podia are in
focus
this is accomplished in stitching and z
projection algorithms for all time
points within the kinetic
whether early on when little invasion
has taken place
and the tumor oids are smaller or at the
later stages of invasion
when invadopodia have extended out into
the major gel
to a much greater extent
the final step of the process was to
quantify the extent of invasion
two separate cellular analyses were
performed on the images
captured doing our in our inhibitor
experiment using a titration of the
selective hsp inhibitor 17 aag
in the first the primary cellular
analysis capabilities
available in gen 5 were used in addition
to changes
in bright field signal within the image
between pixels containing portions of
the tumoroid
and background to place detailed
objective one
that you see in the picture at the top
left of the slide
around the complete invading 3d
structure despite
the level of compound treatment
when the area at each time point is
normalized
to the original area of the tumoroid at
time zero
to creative ratio and then plotted over
time
you can see how the different
concentrations of 17 aag
inhibitor inhibit invasion in a dose
dependent manner a second
cellular analysis was also performed
using
the primary and secondary cellular
analysis capabilities available in gen 5
to measure the area solely by
non-invading
cells within the tumoroid in order to
determine the meta
the metastatic ability of three in vitro
models
whether uninhibited or following
treatment
it is important to be able to
distinguish between area covered
by cells within the original tumeric and
covered by invadopodia as the more
densely packed
non-invasive propagating cells appear
darker
compared to a podium in a bright field
image
as you can see by looking at the outer
edges of the tumeroid
in the top picture closer to the yellow
object mask this additional change in
signal
in the original placement of a secondary
mask
to exclude the invading areas of each
tumoroid
and separate the area covered by the two
portions of the entire 3d structure
by applying the secondary mask around
non-invaded
uh non-invasive portions of the tumeroid
differences in the invasive qualities of
the two
glioblastoma form a cell types
were tested with that we tested then
become clear
the area covered by invadopodia for
u87 fibroblast tumors increases
dramatically
over the seven day incubation period ln
229
fibroblast tumoroids by comparison show
little
increase in an invader podia over the
same time
this dual analysis therefore has the
potential to determine
not only how rapidly tumorized cells are
propagating
but also the invasive nature of the cell
model
in the final portion of my presentation
i'm going to cover
imaging and analysis of organoid models
specifically 3d
small intestinal organoids organoids
made from primary cells or stem cells
or excised from primary tumors are being
used with greater frequency
as they not only take advantage of the
benefits
of being cultivated in 3d they also
contain
appropriate cell types that have not
been immortalized
potentially introducing unwanted changes
in cell function
small intestinal organoids for instance
are now being used in oncology research
as part of gastrointestinal infectious
disease research
and even toxicity studies
on testimony by embedding intestinal
crypts or
stem into matrigel or collagen
form three-dimensional structures
throughout the well
within the hydrogel therefore it's
necessary again to be able to
image the organoids using a z-stacking
procedure
the movie files made from z-stack images
uh show how different portions of the
structure
including budding like
captured at the varying z heights and
i'm going to show you those movie files
now for two
organoids that we captured using
brightfield imaging
again i'll show you that one more time
z projection algorithms again creates uh
final in focus images that can be used
for
a variety what you're seeing here
and then to perform simple label-free
analyses to determine organoid
size and area changes in bright field
signal can be used to place
cellular analysis object masks around
the objects
such as you see in the picture at the
top left of the slide
addition of a digital phase contrast
processing step can also be performed on
the bright field images digital space
contrast is an
algorithm in gen 5 that creates a phase
contrast like
image from the brightfield one as you
see in the image at the bottom right of
the slide
this processing step can then increase
the contrast
between areas of the image containing
the organoid
and background increasing the accuracy
of
object masking creating two methods to
perform
analysis
another common analysis performed with
intestinal organoids
is to monitor organoid health after
treatment
healthy organoids as you saw in the
previous
slides and as i'll show here
continue to create crypts that contain
stem cells
which butt off of the main spheroidal
structure
if the organoids are treated or modified
in any way
it affects health the budding process
will be greatly diminished or faced
altogether leaving the original
sphere
so then to perform the analysis even
though you're seeing adapti
rfp bright field channel overlay in the
picture on the left
only the bright field image is required
masking of the organoids is performed as
i explained
in the previous slide and then a custom
metric
is created in the gen 5 software to
create
or to calculate spikiness which takes
into account the area
and perimeter of each masked object
you can see the spikiness formula near
the bottom
right of the slide which takes into
account
the organoids circularity index
organoid area is in the numerator
of the grenoid perimeter is in the
denominator
as you can see in the picture on the
right side of the slide
healthy budding organoids have a much
longer perimeter
than non-budding organoids that are much
more cylindrical
the larger perimeter value decreases the
fraction
and when that number is subtracted from
one
the final thickness value increases
you can see in the two organoids that
i have huncher that the spikiness value
correlates
well to opinoids with a higher degree of
budding
a second way that organoid health can be
quantified is by performing a count of
the buds
containing the stem cells because the
stem cells are highly proliferative
when adding an edu proliferation
fluorescent probe
the buds will emit a bright signal
whereas other areas of the organoid emit
little to no
signal which you can see in the rfp
image in the middle of the slide using
the bright field
signal from the complete organoid and
the rfp
signal from the eu stain a spot counting
procedure
is set up in gen 5. first a primary mask
is placed around the
entire organoid using the chain the
change in bright field signal
as i explained in the previous slide
spots are then applied to treat each bud
as a spot typically spots are
very small in size so here minimum
and maximum object size are increased to
and
to accommodate the size of the buds
using the change in rfp signal masks
are placed around the buds and the
number of spots
is counted and linked to each organoid
by comparing the average spot count
you know to the treatment the effect on
organoid health can then be assessed
so in conclusion the citation 5 or
citation 5 in combination with the bio
spa
provides easy to perform robust methods
to perform a variety of oncology
applications if you'd like to learn more
about what i've covered here today i
invite you to visit
our this page on biotech.com here
here you can assess a number of
different published application notes
guides and white papers you can also
talk to your local
sales personnel and field scientists to
get the answers that you need
with that i'd like to thank you for your
time and attention
thank you brad after that informative
presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located at the far left of your screen
so let's start
we already have some great questions
coming in from our audience members
our first question is michelle mediated
i
[Music]
thank you susie that's a great question
um so
the answer is yes uh we certainly have
done this
with um a number of um other
applications
as well as uh out in the field within um
uh quite a few different customers that
are looking to create you know as i
mentioned previously in my talk more
advanced um co-cultures where they're
mixing uh if we go back to the t-cell
example
um their cancer cell model
plus potentially t cells or car t
cells macrophages so on and so forth and
each of those
cell types can certainly be stained
with different um cell tracker dyes or
there's other types of methods
to uh sustain cells
um before they're added together and
then again with the
the four different imaging channels
that the citation can hold at one time
you can see you know um either the
the combination of all the cell types
together uh
with something like uh brightfield or
you can use the individual fluorescence
channels to see the effect of
of each individual cell type in a cult
culture
if you wanted to track invasion for
let's say an extended period of time
such as longer than seven days does
biotech have a solution to keep fresh
media on the
invading rights
another great uh right right yep yep
another great
great question and this is something
that's asked of us um
quite quite a number of times whether
that's
for uh you know people looking to do
a tumor invasion or if you think about
other types
of um applications that take
uh you know a week or weeks at a time
like uh stem cell differentiation um
[Music]
other or the the induced cytotoxicity
applications again um those can
you know literally take weeks you know
21 28 days is not uncommon so of course
um you know it's one thing to uh
to put um cell models whether they're 3d
uh or 2d into um
you know into an image or an imager and
an incubator
but of course um even with with 3d after
a certain amount of time
uh the media starts to lose you know
um the uh the components um
that uh the cells are going to need to
maintain
viability so what we can do actually is
um
whether we uh combine this as
in kind of an online system with the
uh the bio spa and the citation that i
talked about
um earlier uh you can combine
a third instrument which would be a
liquid handler that then can be accessed
with the robot and basically
we have developed a new method
that uh with with the the liquid handler
called the multiflo fx this
can be fitted with um
with peristaltic pumps and cassettes
that are specialized to work with
unattached
cell models such as
obviously you know 3d cell models which
are unattached and free-floating in a
well
or uh with the you know the high
interest in immuno oncology
with uh immune cells which obviously are
suspension cells so are not going to be
attached as well and
the the caveat of using this system
is that uh with the peristaltic pumps
you have the ability to
uh have a very fine control of the
aspiration speed
and the dispense speed of the liquid
either coming out of the well
or going into the well and you can also
move the pins
the tubes that are going to be used for
aspiration and dispense
away from the cell model uh
to make sure that you're not aspirating
the cells up uh
obviously during the media exchange you
know um to to avoid that so
um so that really um gives the ability
to then
again like i said either with the biospa
this can be done um
in a complete automated fashion so maybe
you want to perform
your imaging every you know 6 hours 12
hours whatever that would be
and then you can perform a media
exchange once a day
and all of that can be programmed now if
you don't want to have that level
of automation then you can just have
the multi-floor effects by itself it's a
very small
instrument it's maybe you know about two
feet by a foot and a half
by about a foot and a half it can easily
fit into
a tissue culture hood and be run as a
stand-alone
instrument as well so it really again
gives you the ability to
maintain um viability by being able to
to put on fresh media when needed
but without having that worry of
am i going to lose my cells when i'm
performing these media
exchanges
thank you for that and we have time for
one more question does
biotech have experienced imaging
primary patient tumors
right um another great question because
obviously you know
all day long you know people have been
talking about
using um you know cell models and
and you know more advanced techniques to
be able to
uh perform your in vitro testing in a
way that's really getting
as close to an in-vivo model
as possible really of course you know
that's the name of the game when you're
looking for
uh you know for developing new
treatments
um for cancer treatments uh you know for
uh for different types of cancer so um
we certainly have
um had a number of researchers that are
using our
instruments um not just use um
you know again in my last example i
talked about
organoids that were created from stem
cells but literally
what they're doing is they're working in
in cooperation
with a hospital or clinic where
um you know they are having um
you know tumor biopsies that are
then you know taken to their um
their lab whether that's at the uh
at the university or in uh uh
pharmaceutical
biotech setting um and then they're you
know they're taking
small portions of that either putting it
in
um the wells of a microplate or on a
dish
or on a slide um and then you know
performing that type of
imaging again which which you know
obviously is
is a three-dimensional model it's not
necessarily a sphere
but it's still a three-dimensional um
model so
so yes we we certainly can do that um
and then you know certain different um
uh
probes um can be added uh to enable to
see
different you know again certain cell
types or
certain um phenotypic uh
types of um uh effects um
with the with the you know these primary
um you know cancer tumor um models
so um so yeah i would again i would you
know we have lots of
um examples of of this
and you know like i said the other you
know the other things that i've talked
about in
the um in the presentation so i guess
maybe to to close before we close i'll
just mention one more time
that um you know if if anybody would
like to learn
more certainly you know a great place to
start
is our um is our website and you can
look at all the different applications
but we have a really a great wealth of
um field scientists uh not
only in the us but you know all all
across the world
that can certainly help you out um and
answer any questions that
um that you might have we all work
together as a team
to make sure that you're getting you
know the information that you need
and you know the most out of the um the
instruments that you're um that you're
using
i want to thank you again brad for
sharing this information with us today
rob lawson thank you and i want to thank
our audience
for your questions and for your
participation
have a great day until next time bye-bye
thank you everyone